come on give me a cuddle
oh my god oh my god
it's the first time izzy's hugged her
dad since march
how long has it been since we've not
been able to do that
a long while ago regular testing's
changed life at this care home
the vaccine could transform it it'll
just be fantastic i can
i can come around once or twice a week
and we can go for our walks
just to be able to sit next to him and
for him to hold my hand he's always
wanting to hold my hand
it'll just be some step forward to a
little bit of normality again
you can start to see the light now
homes are top priority but logistics
mean residents at least
may not be vaccinated until after
hospital staff
my heart absolutely breaks for all the
relatives who see these as
you know golden tickets to be able to
get back to the loved ones i can't
understand how the government have not
planned procedures
for the vaccine that we are going to be
getting because they've known for a
while
that these vaccines are there so we
would have thought those logistical
plans would have been put in place
high on the list over 80s and health and
social care workers but some
feel they've been forgotten alexander's
29 severely disabled and in a care home
he's hurting himself he's not sleeping
those who are living
with this separation have to have
some consideration as well and i just
keep my fingers crossed that the message
gets through
that they they need to include everybody
in care homes that the distress is equal
for the younger people as well in the uk
age
is a primary factor but in france also
at the front of the queue taxi drivers
and others in contact with the public
it's going to take quite some time to
get down to some of the average age of
taxi drivers which is it's sort of 50
and 60 years old
but because taxi drivers and other
transport workers are exposed to a
higher interact higher amount of
interactions with people
we feel that that should be taken into
account ethnic minority groups aren't
specifically prioritized either despite
high risk for covid the emphasis instead
is on local
uptake these communities have been
disproportionately affected
largely because they have been
overrepresented in front line
key worker professions and also because
of their
wider health and pre-existing conditions
for me i think a mention
of black and asian minority ethnic
communities within the
party list would have seemed sensible
details will evolve during vaccine
rollout but most can expect next year to
be their year
meanwhile every day counts
[Music]
adele robinson sky news